un jour il vint beaucoup de monde chez
nous les hommes ont très comme dans une
église et les femmes faisaient le signe
de la croix en sortant je me glissais
dans la chambre de mes parents et je fus
bien étonné de voir que ma mère avait
une grande bougie allumée près de son
lit mon père se penchait sur le pied du
lit pour regarder ma mère qui dormait
les mains croisées sur sa poitrine
ainsi commence le roman Marie-Claire
écrit par une pauvre couturière
malvoyante qui vit à leur apparie mais
qui est né en 1863 à Sancoins dans le
Berry ce roman obtient en 1910 le prix
féminin est vendu à 100 000 exemplaires
il est salué notamment par Alain
Fournier l'auteur du grand moule c'est
ici à Sainte Montaine entre Berry et
Sologne que ce roman finalement prend
place et c'est dans le musée de la même
commune que nous allons nous rendre pour
découvrir la vie de Marguerite Audoux
bonjour Benjamin chausserand nous sommes
donc au musée Marguerite Audoux elle est
née en 1863 à Sancoins dans le
département du Cher bien sûr elle porte
alors un nom bizarre elle s'appelle
Marguerite Don Quichotte oui
effectivement alors il faut savoir que
donc il choque et les noms de famille de
son père il avait été abandonné et donc
c'est le nom qu'on lui a donné un peu
par hasard lorsqu'il était enfant alors
le père avait été abandonné la fille
l'est à son tour et elle va se retrouver
et bien tout simplement à l'orphelinat
l'orphelinat catholique bien sûr qui se
trouve à Bourges oui tout à fait elle
reçoit alors une éducation de la part
des soeurs donc elle apprend notamment
la lecture mais également des des
travaux manuels comme par exemple la
couture et cette éducation elle va la
poursuivre d'une façon un peu abrupte
puisque à l'âge de 14 ans et bien on
décide qu'il faut lui trouver un métier
ce sera donc bergère oui bergère à
Sainte-Montaine donc elle est placée
dans une ferme béruet qui fait donc sur
la route de Pierrefitte-sur-Sauldre
l'histoire de Marguerite oudou
malheureusement et l'histoire de tous
les enfants abandonnés au tournant du
siècle fin 19e début 20e ce sont des
histoires souvent douloureuses oui
absolument et c'est vrai que au-delà de
l'écrivaine on peut apprécier le
parcours de Marguerite oudou en tant que
femme et en tant qu'être humain parce
que beaucoup à sa place auraient subi
cette fatalité mais elle au contraire
elle a puisé dans tout ce négatif la
sensibilité les émotions nécessaires
pour les écrire dans dans Marie-Claire
finalement son tout premier roman
autobiographique
penchons-nous maintenant sur l'oeuvre
littéraire de Marguerite Audoux à
singularité son exemplarité aussi au
début du 20e siècle et c'est l'écrivain
Bernard Marie Garraud qui nous
l'explique
bonjour Bernard marie-garo vous avez
beaucoup écrit sur Marguerite oudoux
vous la connaissez bien et tout
particulièrement ce livre Marie-Claire
que vous avez étudié alors nous sommes
ici à berruez la ferme qui est en fait
au coeur même de l'intrigue de
Marie-Claire cette œuvre magnifique qui
obtient le Prix féminin en 1910 voilà
qui est dans l'esprit électeurs est
vraiment représentatif de la Sologne
puisque c'est s'assologue qu'elle
réécrit alors moment important
effectivement puisque elle va passer
quatre ans ici les deux premières années
avec des bons maîtres comme on dit et
puis les choses se gâtent les deux
années suivantes ou elle est confrontée
à la dureté de la patronne des tailles
aggravants elle tombe amoureuse du frère
Henri des lois et on la chasse donc
absolument les proches de ces 18 ans et
elle retourne chez les bonnes soeurs qui
l'envoie à Paris
et là c'est 20 années de misère aussi
qui se profile pour revenir à ce séjour
là évidemment et il découvre aussi la
lecture et le plaisir probablement que
procure les histoires la littérature
pour elle c'est l'occasion quand même de
revenir sur ces premiers moments où nous
sommes là à béruet où elle a vécu quand
même ce traumatisme
d'être est conduite par un premier amour
et on va retrouver ça dans toute son
œuvre il y aura toujours un peu les
mêmes thèmes les mêmes structures qui
réapparaissent Marie-Claire c'est un
petit miracle un petit miracle parce que
Marguerite au dos n'était absolument pas
prédestiné à écrire un jour encore moins
avoir un succès littéraire je vous
rappelle qu'elle a vendu 100 000
exemplaires de ce Marie-Claire en 1910
est obtenu le Prix féminin un miracle
elle ne se prenait pas pour une
écrivaine
après 1910 après le prix féminin moi il
y avait des réceptions etc on la
cherchait partout elle était au cuisine
en train de tourner une sauce
ça c'était Marguerite audio elle a
commencé à se prendre pour un écrivain
que au troisième roman de la ville aux
moulins comme par hasard qui est qui
n'est pas le meilleur voilà
lisez Marie-Claire et quand vous l'aurez
lu sans vouloir blesser personne vous
demanderez quelle est parmi nos
écrivains et je parle des plus glorieux
celui qui eu pu écrire un tel livre avec
cette mesure impeccable cette pureté et
cette grandeur rayonnante c'était le
conseil de lecture du principal critique
littéraire du début du 20e siècle Octave
Mirebeau un conseil que l'on peut encore
prodiguer 100 ans plus tard